antoine peillon bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
quatre crs mise en examen pour violences
volontaires lors de lors de l'acte iii
des gilets jaunes ont souvient de la
vidéo de l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre qui a fait le tour du web
on est alors à l'acte iii il y a eu
beaucoup plus d'actes ensuite on
entendait un des gilets jaunes faouzi
lellouche dire il ya eu beaucoup de
plaintes mais peut finalement ont été
suivis quel a été le rôle finalement de
cette vidéo dans le lancement de cette
enquête selon on va écouter jeu sourire
très précis de cette vidéo elle était
d'une violence absolument injustifiable
parce que j'entendais les tentatives de
se justifier des fonctionnaires qui ont
été identifiés les personnes qui ont été
tabassés avec une rare violence ne
présentait aucune menace d'aucune sorte
à l'ordre public
elle s'était réfugiée dans ce restaurant
fast-food parce que dehors régner comme
l'a dit un fonctionnaire une ambiance de
guerre civile mais je vais je vais vous
dire très clairement j'en ai fait
beaucoup là des actes de gilet jaune en
tant que journaliste il y avait
effectivement parfois une atmosphère de
guerre civile mais de la responsabilité
principale des forces de l'ordre si ce
que j'ai vu constamment ce sont des
manifestants qui pour 99% d'entre eux
sont des gens parfaitement normaux
parfaitement pacifique souvent
extrêmement fraternelle d'ailleurs et
qui ont subi pendant un an et demi un
déchaînement de violences policières
la l'événement mon cet événement qui est
rapporté par le parisien est évidemment
intéressant mais il faut lire le
recensement systématique de notre
confrère david dufresne sur halo place
beauvau et sur le site qu'il abrite
maintenant le site de mediapart pour
voir que ce sont des centaines de
violence qui sont absolument
injustifiable dans notre pays et ça
depuis le commencement du
- depuis le commencement du mouvement
des gilets jaunes mais si réalité tu as
commencé avant mais finalement antoine
peillon est ce que c'est la doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre qui doit être revue
ou finalement c'est davantage la vision
du politique des hordes on entendait les
donneurs d'ordre qui doivent là encore
ce finalement se repose sur poser les
bonnes questions
il y a plusieurs facteurs le premier
facteur c'est effectivement une
évolution en france de ce qu'on appelle
la doctrine du maintien de l'ordre et
qui comprend par exemple maintenant
l'autorisation d'usagé d'armes soit
disant non létale mais qui sont en
réalité extrêmement dangereuse et qui
potentiellement sont mortels et qui en
tout cas cause des blessures
irrémédiables
vous pensez bien aux débordements qui
ont été au moins une trentaine les mains
arrachées
voilà les conclusions des visages démoli
et définitivement cette doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre en france est
absolument exceptionnel par rapport à ce
qui se pratique en europe partout en
europe
le défenseur des droits monsieur toubon
a constamment plusieurs fois depuis deux
ans alertés sur le fait que nos
pratiques policières et la doctrine
policière et est absolument inacceptable
deuxième chose les hiérarchies policière
couvre complètement leur leurs agents et
elles sont parfois même responsable
certainement par incitations au moins
tacite de cette violence déchaînée des
forces de l'ordre sur les manifestants
tout simplement pour empêcher qu'il y
ait des manifestations
je peux l'affirmer parce que j'en ai été
le témoin sur de nombreuses
manifestations qui ont été brisées dans
l'oeuf
à peine avait commencé alors
troisièmement troisièmement il y a un
pouvoir politique qu'il gouvernement
français est depuis en tout cas depuis
l'élection d' emmanuel macron les choses
ont empiré de façon spectaculaire
elle était déjà sous françois hollande
et sous nicolas sarkozy en aggravation
constante mais avec l'arrivée à l'elysée
de d'emmanuel macron on a senti qu'il y
avait autorisation de faire comme on
voulait et dernier facteur
il est très important il est un facteur
politique
nous avons constaté les policiers avec
lesquels je suis en relation des
officiers de police a été telle gestion
de la scion depuis une quinzaine
d'années au moins une dérive idéologique
dans les effectifs chez les ch et les
policiers chez les policiers en très
grande proportion aujourd'hui il y a une
mentalité politique qui est une
mentalité d'extrême droite assumé des
insignes fascistes sont parfois arboré
sur les yeux sur les uniformes des
petits drapeaux ou d'autres d'autres
manifestations visuels de l'organisation
fascistes se retrouvent dans les
commissariats voir ou fenêtres
là encore vous trouverez sur le site du
journal mediapart énormément
d'informations c'est pas tout la police
antoine peillon c'est pas tout la police
ce n'est absolument pas tout la police
mais c'est une proportion suffisamment
importante aujourd'hui pour inquiéter
voir pour décourager des autres leurs
collègues je peux vous dire que y
compris en manifestation j'ai recueilli
des témoignages d'officiers de
gendarmerie ou de police qui était
souvent qui avait de la bouteille qui
étaient des gens qui était officier
depuis de nombreuses années et qui était
complètement dégoûté il n'y a pas
d'autre mot dégoûté par le comportement
qu'il voyait contre lequel il ne pouvait
rien faire de certains fonctionnaires de
police malheureusement très grand nombre
alors il aura en doute a fallu 18 mois
pour retrouver les auteurs présumés des
violences
est-ce que ce délai est il anormalement
longs puisque avec les vidéos et la
connaissance par les autorités des
unités sur place on aurait pu imaginer
que cela aille plus vite non moi cette
écoute et c'est de l'ordre du ridicule
n'importe quelle enquête judiciaire sur
des sur des faits
beaucoup plus difficile à identifier
étant donné qu'il n'y a parfois pas de
vidéo il n'ya pas d'enregistrement vont
évidemment beaucoup plus vite
il y a comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure il ya une couverture on appelle
ça couvrir manifeste une couverture
manifeste des exactions d'un grand
nombre de policiers par leur hiérarchie
l'igpn s'est illustré au point que
d'ailleurs certains demandent sa
dissolution s'est illustré par une
passivité voire par une complicité
évidente vis-à-vis des fonctionnaires
qui se livrent à des deux véritable
délice ce sont de véritables délit est
pour l'instant l'impunité est quasi
totale tout à l'heure un entretien que
vous avez diffusé à juste titre
signalait qu'il y a des centaines des
centaines de plaintes qu'ils ne sont
même pas instruite et qui n'aboutiront à
rien
merci beaucoup antoine peillon d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste grand reporter au
journal la croix et à hauteur de coeur
de boxeur le vrai combat de christophe
dettinger aux éditions les liens qui dit